you can also watch all of our past
programs anytime at booktv.org
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
a house divided coming to you from
abraham lincoln bookshop in chicago
my name is bjorn skaptesen and i will be
the administrator for this program
the book we're going to talk about today
is lincoln in private by ronald c white
and you'll learn more about that book in
just a moment
i think with that i am ready to turn you
over to your host for today daniel
weinberg from abraham lincoln bookshop
daniel
welcome to
the house divided i'm average i'm
abraham lincoln i wish
i'm daniel weinberg and we're here at
the abraham lincoln book shop in chicago
in our broadcast studio embedded in our
shop and wish ron you were here with us
as you have been in the past but your
next book we hope to have you do that of
course we're here for your latest book
which i'll
talk about in a moment lincoln in
private and uh if you're watching this
we will have a book signed for you and
with book plates just like this
uh our logo was on it that came from
carl sandberg years and years ago
and will and ron is going to be signing
those for us and for you when you order
a book from us
let's introduce ron first
ronald c white jr is a reader at the
huntington library senior fellow of the
trinity forum in washington dc
he's taught at ucla colorado college
whitworth university and the princeton
theological seminary
he's lectured at the white house been
interviewed for the pbs newshour
and lectured on lincoln truly all over
the world
some of his previous books include
american ulysses
the life of ulysses s grant
a lincoln a biography
lincoln's greatest speech
the second inaugural
liberty and justice for all racial
reform and the second gospel
and numbers of others
his latest book as you've seen is
lincoln in private
what his most personal recollections
tell us about our greatest president
it's a random house book
328 pages fully illustrated
and is 28
now
as i said you're at a house divided yes
one of our shows here at uh our 83 year
old antiquarian shop
uh but we're comfortable as you can see
in the 21st century even though we're
19th century oriented
and we've been broadcasting these author
interviews
now called the house divided since 2004
really inspired by brian lamb's
uh work on c-span
next time we hope ron you'll be here at
the broadcast studio embedded in our
shop
and we welcome all our viewers to drop
into our shop here in chicago by
appointment
we're thankful to c-span for following
our programming for many years
and we welcome c-span's viewers to
follow both our live streaming
broadcasts house divided which are on
right now in our artifact show take a
break with history because on every
friday at 1 pm central
we also thank our publishing partners
random house
and their publicist rachel parker who
have been instrumental in putting
together this day of release event yes
this is the release day for ron's new
book
and we hope you will follow all our book
signing events with major authors in the
fields of lincoln the civil war and the
u.s presidents
watching this on c-span uh a little
later on and these will be on youtube as
well so you can go there
and we'll have copy signed with the book
plate that i showed you
so i hope you will sign up by your email
at our
our website so you can receive notice of
future events
well
ron
this book to me i've been in the
business of
lincolniana for 49 years now
and i have to say this is among the
finest books
yet published on lincoln
which perhaps now total seventeen
thousand titles
because i think you have a sensitivity
into lincoln's words thoughts and
actions
that bring great insight if this is
really a reference book as well
of lincoln's verbiage but it's a look at
him
psychologically emotionally
as a political technocrat
as an ethicist
that's a powerful book to read i was
reading through some of lincoln's words
and i was taken aback i've read them for
so long
it is powerful because you're reading
lincoln in the raw the power of his
verbiage is truly extraordinary these
are not just throwaway musings
and it's also powerful
because as i've maybe intimated of ron
acting as a greek chorus to these words
giving context to lincoln's words
explaining with historical insights
arousing our curiosity into some of the
mysteries
in these
fragments and notes
all the while writing in a manner that
would have made lincoln proud
so
i'm going to first start with the
organization of this book
that cover numerous aspects
of lincoln
and very quickly i'll just read
that
the chapters have one i'm going to call
them frag notes because they're
fragments and notes so i'm calling them
frag notes today
the lyrical lincoln
which uh is subtitled
the trans transcendence of niagara falls
and each one has a subtitle i'll just
tell you what he's covering of the
aspects of lincoln the lyrical lincoln
the humble lincoln
the fiery
defeated republican
principal
and outraged lincoln
the unity lincoln
the kentuckian
and the theological
lincoln
that's what's covered in these ten
chapters
uh and then uh an appendix so
ron you dissect these ten different
maybe 11 different notes in these 10
chapters
um
we'll go to the appendix later on
because there are 111 fragments frag
notes that you found
what was your overriding consideration
when choosing the separate chapter frag
notes in this book
you first choose the aspects
or do they just pop out at you anyway
well first of all dan thank you so much
for being a part of your program once
again it's a very real delight and
privilege
this is a long winding story for me when
i first encountered lincoln it was at
the huntington library exhibit in 1993.
i was teaching history at ucla and i had
a choice of offering a seminar of my own
i was had us reading a compendium of
lincoln's words and when i came to the
second inaugural i was very much struck
by it
but i wanted to know what was the
antecedent of this so i learned that
there was a document and brown
university
john hay lincoln's young secretary had
titled it lincoln didn't title any of
these called the meditation on the
divine will
so i traveled from southern california
to brown university to hold this little
piece of blue lined paper in my hands i
had no idea at the time that there were
so many many many notes
and i've came to the conclusion that
most people didn't know this oh some of
these are familiar some are in the
biographies of lincoln but i thought we
needed to see lincoln whole and when i
contacted daniel worthington who is the
editor of the lincoln papers there in
springfield he said well we believe
there's 111 of these notes that have
survived i'm sure lincoln wrote hundreds
of them but 111 have survived so i
wanted in a sense to put before people
the private lincoln behind the public
lincoln
so those aspects the unity the outrage
those is that how you first organize it
or did as i said as i asked before the
did the fragments just pop out at you
and give you those aspects of lincoln i
think the fragments popped out at me i
didn't want to write a 700 page book so
i made a decision to focus on 10
chapters with 12 fragments i also have
had the privilege this really surprised
me of narrating the audio book usually
only michelle obama or somebody like
that gets to do it but they let me do it
but in the audio book they said well are
there more fragments you'd like to read
so i then read five more
so in a sense i just chose 17 but
there's many more i could have focused
on but i want to have the time as you
suggested in your introduction to take
the time for the reader to sense the
context the style the the different
styles of lincoln very lyrical style
style at niagara falls very different
kind of style in some other fragments
and notes
well
this book
why i think it's
one of the reasons i think it's so
important
is that it belongs on every lincoln
bookshelf
right next to the collected works
by roy basler because you have 111
fragments in here that are his works
they're not all in there
uh another book that's next to it is don
fernbacher's recollected words of
abraham lincoln so those three titles
this one and the other two
belong together as
basically a reference book besides
goodreads period
why do you think that they've been so
overlooked where do most of them reside
that they have not been used
much before
well they're spread across
huge volumes of lincoln's words the
first by nicolet and haye and then by
basler in the 1950s and so we've never
quite seen them together
until quite recently they would have
been in all kinds of different libraries
the lincoln papers project in
springfield through the previous years
has digitized them so they own 110
of the 111.
fortunately for me i knew the gentleman
in dallas texas who owned one of the
greatest fragments of all the fragment
on slavery and he and his curator
allowed me to use that fragment in the
book
one of the things that's wonderful about
this book is that
you show them
the ones in the chapters
right here
in living color
and they really become more than just
showing
what the verbiage was and what they look
like
but you're showing them as artifacts
well you would appreciate that very
important
for people to be able to see
these materials as artifacts how did you
get your
your publisher
to
top four color illustrations in the
middle of this book well my shout out
first shout out goes to my phenomenal
editor caitlin mckenna
she
advocated for this with random house as
you are suggesting this is not
inexpensive
to print things in color and so right in
the center of the book 16 pages in color
and as you also suggest you can see the
kind of real fragment the different
colorizations that they're all on quite
different kinds of paper you really can
see lincoln's handwriting so
shout out to caitlyn she persuaded at
random house and i think this is a real
distinctive part of the book
positively and we're going to show some
of them as we speak of a few of them
it's an impossibility for us to get
through all of this but we'll be here
for hours which i'm ready for frankly
because i have hours of questions but
we'll try to hone it down so the viewer
uh doesn't uh fall asleep hopefully um
you mentioned
lincoln's handwriting and how the
lincoln papers project was helpful with
kelly closing there we both know uh
helped you in understanding
how lincoln's handwriting changed over
time
i myself in all my years of seeing and
handling linkedin writings have
identified for instance five different
a's capital a's that he used that i look
for
i've identified that he sometimes use
one
dot two dots or forgets to put dots
after that a
uh there's one signature i call a roller
coaster signature the way it goes
he doesn't cross his t's those are
crossed to the right above the word not
on the t
and many times i found during his
presidency he hearkens back
to his earlier signatures in the
1850s 40s and even the 30s
so what did she tell you
about lincoln's handwriting and how it
changed
well i asked her that question because
she'd been examining it for years and
her observation which is a general
observation yours is very helpful more
specific is that she felt that over time
as he aged his handwriting often became
smaller and more rounded
that he had learned as everyone in his
generation would have learned penmanship
but then through the years it began to
change and she could watch it change
through the years
i'll say this though when he when he
signed his full name abraham lincoln
which he had to do for every
uh
official document whether it was lawyer
but mostly as president i think the
papers project has come up with
something like
i think i've kind of come up with 35 000
of them out of the 100 000 plus that are
in his hand that he had to sign full
the military commissions he signed large
most of the time sometimes stanton
signed it so large he had no room but uh
stanton later made it smaller and he
became large and showed off his
signature to a man that he was sending
off maybe to be killed
um you also mentioned in here how these
frag notes many times
follow a book that he had just read or
recently read
so there are connections from the books
you read to some of these
give us an idea about that please well
first of all the the traditional view of
lincoln is that he didn't read many
books that he mostly read newspapers
and what i found interesting and the
question i brought to the challenge task
myself is
did these notes make their way into his
finished polished public speeches
most often they did not
but for example
he
he reads
this book slavery ordained of god
a book by presbyterian minister
frederick ross in 1857
and this is an interesting story because
william herndon had encouraged him to
subscribe to various anti-slavery
newspapers
then lincoln said to herndon but i also
want to subscribe to the richmond
newspaper and the charleston courier and
herndon said well why would you do that
and he said we need both sides at the
table
so one thing that i think is important
for people today to understand he wanted
both sides of the table so he read this
pro-slavery book by frederick ross
presbyterian minister from huntsville
alabama
and although he didn't agree with it and
would finally offer a note in many ways
challenging it he wanted to try to
understand what what he was saying and
then he would respond and i think this
was his kind of grist his intellectual
curiosity
which although it didn't it was never
quoted in a speech i think it was part
of his thinking about how am i going to
attack slavery
well
that that brings to the question that
we've started to talk about already the
usage
of these frag notes uh now he wrote in
order to speak
uh has been that's been brought up by
numbers and i and i kind of agree with
that that's what he was writing for
and uh certainly the underlining
he does on
on many of his words for emphasis i
think is for emphasis of speaking not
just thinking
and of course as you suggest his writing
used to hone his thoughts and studying
the other side of an issue like ross
so is that is those really the
main reasons to hone his thought and to
give speeches even though
these specifically didn't always make it
into them
i think yes you're right he he did this
to hone his thought
but he's also sort of debating within
himself
this is this is part of what i think is
so important in understanding him and i
would say any leader that we want to
vote for today his intellectual
curiosity
he it wasn't just that he had arrived at
a conclusion but it's the way he arrives
at the conclusion
there's a logical lincoln very logical
lincoln sometimes i almost can imagine
him as a lawyer
walking up and down in a courtroom kind
of prosecuting a case against slavery
advocates
and so this is a way of him working out
intellectually what he thinks about an
issue sometimes the notes are ahead of
what he will say
in other words he he's he's a little
more circumspect maybe in a public
speech he's not quite ready to say
something in his anti-slavery we've
watched the development of islamic
slavery thought but you can see the
foundation of that in these notes
well i want to ask you about some of the
commonalities that they have yes uh
he delves into the historical you you
note many times
another is that he
many times begins with a challenge and
ends with some call to action yes
uh
are there other commonalies besides you
can talk about these
and is this common in most of his
speeches as well
well you've determined or described it
well that
he's never talking about this just to
have an intellectual conversation but as
you suggest and i try to point out
often there's a call to action at the
end
but you don't get to that call to action
until you've taken the time to
understand the issue
and so lincoln is wanting to deal with
that
for example he's very concerned when he
joins the republican party that he
doesn't think that the adherents of the
party are quite aware of how much the
party is being charged with sectionalism
that this only a sectional party and he
thinks we've got to deal with this issue
but that at the end of the two notes
that are on the republican party that i
include well what are we there for to do
about this he's always asking what are
we therefore about to do
we're going to show that and talk about
that a little bit more as we go along uh
of course
you note how shut-mouthed lincoln was
uh
as is
as his law partners third law partner
billy herndon uh pointed out and
described him in shut them out
give us an example
of how his inner feelings
really show off in one of these frag
notes that you
have here as an historian what do you
believe it shows of the man
well first of all just the whole
question of feelings
i think that we need to understand that
lincoln born in kentucky
moving as a young boy to southern
indiana
grew up in what we would call the second
great awakening
his parents attended baptist churches
that were extremely emotional and from a
very young age lincoln reacted against
this kind of emotionalism
in religion but emotionalism generally
and so he was very wary of kind of
feelings
he wanted to be a rational person he was
a thoughtful person
so i found it quite remarkable when
after he runs for the senate senate we
remember was elected by state
legislatures
he is defeated in 1855 he leads on the
first seven ballots the big issue is the
kansas-nebraska act whether slavery will
be permitted to go west into the
territories and even though his
adherents want him to stay in the race
he finally concludes he cannot win and
withdraws so that a democrat at the time
lyman trumbull but who is anti-nebraska
will win well lincoln's very magnanimous
in public afterwards it's okay i'm i'm
all right but then in this remarkable
note he talks about the fact that his
life is nothing but a failure
nothing but a flat failure he would
never have said that in public he would
never have expressed those kind of
deep-seated feelings and that's what
makes the notes so important here we can
talk he never expected us to read them
we're not going to see them
at the lincoln bookshop in 2021 he's
writing for himself
but he expresses this really heartfelt
feeling my life is a failure
a flat failure boy that just struck me
but yet in that failure
in chapter four you have the that
failure note maybe we can see it um
he spoke of that in 1856
but he ends on a positive note he does
and
please explain to us the import of
lincoln of that in lincoln's character
that he had that failure
but he ends more positively so he can go
on especially since he was such a
depressive character as we know right
well i've i've had the experience of
speaking to lots of high school students
who are studying 11th grade american
history
and i'll often ask the question how long
do you think it took lincoln to write
these notes
and they'll say two minutes three
minutes four minutes and i said how
about an hour or two or three and i
think what happened often was lincoln's
writing this and this note might have
happened
and suddenly he pauses and he almost
says to himself wow this is pretty
self-pitying this is pretty negative
and then he turns it around as you
suggest
and so he says i have no uh
i'm not jealous of stephen douglas for
all the success that he has achieved and
he ends on a very positive note that he
wants what he calls the
the oppressed of my species to be lifted
up that's what my goal is so he does
turn it around i think many times
lincoln probably paused in writing these
notes and said oh my goodness
and then takes it in a different
direction
you know he just
reminded me that uh when i see lincoln's
depressions and he had numbers of them
sometimes where his friends took away
knives and scissors from him they were
fearful of in taking his own life
why didn't he do that
because positively
he wanted to make a difference in the
world before he left it yes and so again
that shows
positiveness
that brought him out of the depression
in melancholy that he could continue on
with his life and work and not do away
with it because of his deep depression
of the time i'm glad you reminded me of
that
uh another thing that's nice about this
book by the way is that each chapter
has
a preface meaning
a lincoln image
that shows him
at the time of the note what he looked
like
so that's another part that people can
enjoy they'll be able to see
lincoln at time of failure and what he
looked like at that time
but we're speaking of lincoln's
character
you write that lincoln
quote
embodied the ideal of the
self-constructed man unquote
please explain that concept and how it
applied to lincoln
well here i tip my hat to my
fellow historian daniel walker howe
for he argues persuasively that what it
meant in the 19th century sort of a
self-made man we might say became very
different in the 20th century in the
20th century we associated with someone
who made it economically who made wealth
who advanced themselves but that was not
how argues what it was meant in the 19th
century
self-constructed meant someone who was
on a moral journey and whose moral life
was in a kind of moral uplift and
lincoln almost like benjamin franklin
was kind of taking personal inventory of
himself
he recognized that as a young man he was
sometimes given to
bad humor to attacking others to sarcasm
he was aware of those qualities in
himself and he wanted to move beyond
them and he did
and so this is what it means to be
self-constructed
that lincoln is on a personal
moral odyssey in his life and he's in he
grows and he changes and that's what i
think makes him so attractive
the viewers that are listening in need
to read
what lincoln wrote
hear hear it within your own mind
in other words
buy the book because we're not going to
be able to go over everything in here
and there's such a power as i mentioned
earlier about lincoln and the greek
chorus that ron provides to help us
along the journey of understanding it
now then it starts out your book with
the niagara falls uh note that he wrote
and as you say is surprisingly lyrical
and we're not going to read it here you
have to read it for yourself
but it really is that
but you write that he was also crafty in
the details
that he discovered the details of the
falls such as where the water came from
and uh the tonnage of the water that
came through
uh why do you think he wrote that down
uh
why why did he use all that in this note
to remind himself
why
well of course
remember he was
interested in rivers and
sort of engineering and all of that sort
of stuff throughout his entire life he
was always interested in causation what
was causing this incredible phenomenon
what i try to say in the context of
understanding the context for the reader
is that young america felt somewhat
inferior
to england and europe in terms of it
could not match the kind of cultural
literary musical artistic but what it
could offer that could not be offered in
europe was natural beauty and before
yellowstone or yosemite it was niagara
falls that was the great attraction for
americans of lincoln's generation
and so he goes there he writes this down
surely he might be thinking well maybe i
will use this future in a future way in
a lecture
but he's just captivated by it but wakes
what makes it so interesting again is
that when he comes back
and shares his experience with herndon
hearn had been there himself recently
and herndon makes this amazing comment
that lincoln would have no capacity for
understanding the beauty of niagara
falls that's not the man i know
well herndon didn't know the man because
this fragment shows that lincoln
amazingly had the capacity for
appreciating the beauty of niagara falls
and i want to put this in it does come
chronologically towards the beginning
because mostly we encounter the logical
lincoln but here we encounter the
lyrical lincoln the poetic lincoln able
to get into this experience it and see
it very broadly in terms of what is the
causation of this falls
it's interesting that when i read
through it and got to the end
you had mentioned how this and if there
is there's a comma at the end as if he
went on after this but you know i felt
that it
it was a very powerful ending it
actually
ended where i think it should have ended
maybe he put the comma and said no i'm
done i can't do any better
i think it's just a
fabulous letter and i think or no
lincoln may have seen that he had come
to the end everyone should read
herndon's reaction because as you say
now he didn't know lincoln i think
you're learning more about
william herndon than you are about
lincoln when uh herndon reacts to this
the other thing that he uses in here is
the word indefinite
and
he used that word in his dream
that he told later of
of sailing toward an indefinite shore
yes so my question really is more about
the digitalization of lincoln's words
maybe a concordance although now we
don't need it printed we could get it
online i suppose
um but is there some sort of digital
concordance is it would it be useful of
all lincoln's words and the number of
times he used them
well i i never thought about that we
need it don't we this would be fantastic
i mean you've made a connection here i
had not thought of that connection
the the word indefinite yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i'll send you my bill on the morning
that's your next book
okay yeah right
now he gives one of the one of the more
famous
uh
frag notes that you had a lot longer
than a fragment
is his advice to a budding lawyer
now i wanted to show because we can here
at the abraham lincoln bookshop
we have original artifacts such as this
note
written by uh lincoln in the hand of him
but for logan and lincoln his second law
partner and he's writing a price a p
here i think it is uh in a case of
justice and justice versus garth
and about the costs of it um so we this
is some of the things we have this is
what his handwriting looked like as a
lawyer
so
um
there are many aspects to the the advice
that he gives here
not to take a fee in advance
uh which is an interesting thought and
of course his emphasis on honesty
now ward hill lammon who was a fellow
lawyer and later a uh uh
helped guard lincoln wasn't there the
night he he needed to be but lincoln had
sent him off to richmond
on april 14th so he wasn't there
but
lincoln was a politician and a lawyer
and lammon
said of him i once had a note in which
he said this
that lincoln when he talked about
honesty lincoln could stretch the truth
when necessary
so please comment not only on lammon's
observation because that honesty is in
this note uh very important uh but also
uh what you think the most cogent
arguments he made are in this in this
long note
well he begins in a remarkable way the
note is dated by basler
to be 1850
we remember that lincoln served one term
in congress
1847-49
he returned home he had taken a very
strong stand against president james
polk and the war with mexico
and i think he thought and many may have
agreed with him that perhaps his
political career was over
so he returns to becoming a lawyer
full-time traveling the eighth judicial
circuit in central illinois
and so basler dates the
document as july 1850 i think it
probably was a little later than that i
find it that lincoln would be rather
audacious for him to
write a lecture to lawyers right away
why did he write the lecture well i
consider that
he was now spending 175
85 90 days out on this circuit
and the practice of becoming a lawyer
was to become a clerk in a law office
and as lincoln became a very well-known
lawyer many lawyers would have wanted to
serve as a clerk with him but he could
not
he couldn't do that with his schedule
so he offers this lecture
to lawyers to aspiring lawyers
and he begins let's see if we can find
that word here i i really want to read
this
because this is so important just here
we go
i am not
an accomplished lawyer i find quite as
much material for a lecture
in those points where i have failed
as in those where i have been moderately
successful
my goodness
he was an accomplished lawyer
already a famous lawyer
i will say to people can you imagine a
modern leader lawyer politician business
president of a college or university
saying i am not
this says so much about who abraham
lincoln thinks he is
not that he doesn't have ambition he
will use that word a lot
but he also has a sane estimate of
himself
and he really is in a sense defending
the profession of law
that i argue that although the lecture
is directed at aspiring lawyers i think
it's the finest self-portrait we have of
lincoln the lawyer we have the wonderful
lincoln legal papers project
done some years ago where we found all
these papers in the 102 courthouses of
illinois
but this is the best
apprehension of who was lincoln the
lawyer
yeah that's important
and you do you find out the man in that
and also whom he wanted to represent
himself we all want to present ourselves
in the world
and i think that's certainly what he was
doing so if it was later
he was thinking maybe of his uh
of a political career if it was after
the kansas
uh embroglio began
maybe he was thinking that you know he
came right in
to that embroglio
so uh maybe this was a leader and he
wanted to show whom he was as well not a
bad thing if you're going to be putting
yourself out yes
you talked
before briefly of the birth of the
republican party the sectionalism of
parties
and that is one of the most interesting
chapters in this book ron
where he's wrestling with party
affiliation
and you have two fragments there and the
first
well it reminded me uh
just like we might
we might question just which of us
humans is the opposite sex
lincoln questioned just which party was
the real sectional party
yes and so he speaks of the real power
of the south staying silent and letting
the north vie for them
as you quote we get the measures and you
get the men
there was great fluidity in these
parties at this time in the 40s and 50s
all of them in flux
my father might have said we're fluxed
again
but nonetheless today
some might fault
lincoln for not being an abolitionist
being too moderate
on the slavery issue
but as usual in this
fragment this first one
lincoln cuts to the chase
he says they
meaning the abolitionists are righteous
but would rather be right than win
please comment on on this aspect of
lincoln's uh thoughts at this time
well
he had a context for saying that
his great mentor or what he called his
bow ideal was henry clay
and henry clay ran for the presidency
three times
and in one race clay would have won the
presidency
if he could have captured new york
but
he was denied that victory in new york
because the liberty party this would
have been the abolitionist party
received more than 15 000 votes
and so lincoln never forgot that
election and he called these people the
righteous
that they would rather be right
than to win
and so here we see lincoln the very
practical
politician
that we have to win i mean uh
he he he's not always going to follow
the person who he completely agrees with
all of their ideas he did agree with the
ideas of clay
but
he wants the republican party we might
use the term to be a big tent party
it was hard for him at first because his
dna was loyalty he was a loyal whig he
didn't immediately join the republican
party but when he did he wanted it to be
open to everyone
this is another conversation but he was
worried about the nativists but in terms
of the slavery anti-slavery spectrum he
didn't want to draw lines
and he was worried about the
abolitionists because sometimes he felt
they were very self-righteous about
their cause
um
you know we here in illinois by the way
i'm going to now go on to another
chapter that you have
uh we here in illinois say it's the land
of lincoln we do it's on our license
plate
uh indiana rebuts us and say well it's
we are the ones we had them uh as a
young man and of course as the jesuits
say give me the child we have the adult
but
of course kentucky was on his mind a lot
yes and he grew up in an area of
illinois
where a lot of kentuckians also
immigrated here to central illinois
southern illinois being really a border
state just like kentucky
i have we happen to have right now in
our shop
a
little note that he put on an envelope
say in kentucky right there
uh inside the envelope that's now gone
uh was a list of adjutants perhaps from
the state of kentucky that he was that
were recommended to lincoln and uh so
he's
he wrote what was inside there and the
note uh is gone right now i haven't
looked at the papers to see if i could
find it
but
you have
an unused speech that he
what he what he made you know he was on
the inaugural train
and he was right across the river
from kentucky when he could have made
this speech thinking about the slave
right across the river from him
and as you say with this particular
fragment that
except for historian harold holzer whom
we both know well
who devoted three pages to this
really this has been largely ignored and
the speech echoes most of
his important policy as president-elect
and beyond not to allow slavery into the
territories
he just would that was i think the most
important things he ever did to make
sure that he did not
vary from that
hardened position of his
if he had
nothing else may have followed
please give us a comment on this
wonderful speech
well
this is one that's been ignored uh
when did he write it he didn't write it
on the train
he wrote it in springfield
because we find it attached to a first
draft of his first inaugural speech
and you can tell from the speech
and we know from other
factors that he had this great affinity
for kentucky
perhaps he was overly optimistic
in the beginning of 1861 about union
sentiment in kentucky but it was
certainly divided
and so he keeps talking about my fellow
kentuckians now he had spoken in
cincinnati in 1859
and kentuckians had crossed the ohio
river to hear him then
and so he had this great hope that
somehow he could give this speech
he never did
i
imagine as he took the train and
the train arrived coming into cincinnati
he would have looked across the ohio
river towards kentucky and so i think
it's fascinating to say what would he
say to his fellow kentuckians
and in a sense on the one hand he's
wanting to let them know that he has a
great affinity affection for them
on the other hand he wants them to know
that he is not going to step back
from the policies and the ideas that
he's announced
all through his life and that are in his
public words
and if they don't agree with them why
then
that's the whole point of elections that
you can elect someone or defeat someone
in the next election
but i think this has been as you say
apart from harold holzer it's been
completely overlooked and i wanted to be
right here in this book
yeah it's important and an interesting
read
certainly i've not read it before in its
entirety yeah
um
now in in a chapter you called
unit uh
unity lincoln secession and the
constitution
um
you talk about a letter from alexander
stevens who became
the confederate vice president and
initially as you mentioned uh he was
against secession didn't think it should
happen
but in a letter to lincoln he's kind of
leaning
toward the secession movement
i'm wondering if lincoln's
disappointment in stevens
was a reason why he didn't
answer that
letter
why do you think that he was so silent
on that i mean he was he was certainly
not silent on as i mentioned before and
you have the
the issue of
slavery not going into the territories
and that issue
dividing
the nascent republican party
and he said don't in another letter to
thomas corwin of ohio he's he mentioned
don't let's not start talking about live
oak contracts
as he did as a lawyer so why do you
think he was silent to alexander stevens
on such an important issue especially
from someone in the south
well let's remember that he and stephen
served together in the 30th congress
and he and both were wigs and one of the
difficulties for him of leaving the whig
party was it had been a national party
and he was very impressed with stevens a
very thoughtful intellectual person they
really kind of bonded
so when he heard that stevens had given
an address
against the kind of prevailing sentiment
in georgia which was for a succession
he was interested in this and he wrote
to stevens and said my goodness i'd like
to receive that address i'm interested
to know what you think
some have even suggested that perhaps he
was wanting to maybe find some moderate
southerner that he could put into his
cabinet
so stevens sent him the address he read
it
and wrote back but in writing back he
does say to stevens but we have
different ideas about slavery
and and so he stevens writes to him
and you've asked the question dan why
did he not reply
i think this may have been the beginning
of his realizing that it wasn't just the
fire brands of the south who were for
succession but very very sadly people
like stevens who he would have thought
of as moderates he would have thought as
kind of people of intellectual substance
they also were and so this might have
been a turning point for him not simply
just against stevens but beginning to
realize what was really happening in the
south the thinking behind secession but
it gave us the opportunity here that's
the point of the fragment
and i
tip my hat to jonathan white who
suggested to me it should be in my book
is that lincoln has this remarkable
discussion about the relationship of the
declaration and the constitution
which is primary and he'll argue that
it's the declaration that his primary
stands beneath is the foundation of the
constitution and he writes about that at
length he does yeah
and uses this wonderful pro wonderful
verse from the book of proverbs about
the apple of gold that's that's actually
stevens uses that praise and here's
another trait of lincoln lincoln is
remarkable at taking someone else's
words
this is stephen's words
and
digesting them and then saying but i
think my friend stevens it actually
means this not that he was great at
taking someone else's words trying to
understand it empathetically but then
putting a different spin i don't that's
the wrong word different interpretation
of it
was that did he use the ver the words
that he verbiage in this note did he use
them again
yes he did yeah yeah yeah
um you have an interesting they're all
interesting
but another interesting chapter
in the theological lincoln
and those of us who have been toiling in
the
vineyards of lincolniana have always
admired
and known of his capacity to grow
especially in the 50s
but also through the presidency in the
60s
but
as i think you point out it doesn't seem
that we generally allow
that same capacity
in on his theological side
and we don't
dwell into this would you
talk a bit about how
this this fragment and also just
generally
lincoln
especially with
especially with the numbers of men that
he had to send off to be killed and
maimed
how did the theological side of his grow
well here again we need to
take a step back and understand his own
biography
i've mentioned already growing up in the
south
becoming his parents part of the baptist
churches
but then he did what many young adults
do then and now he rejected
his parents faith and when he moves to
new salem and we have this from several
witnesses in the wonderful book
herndon's informants
that he wrote a paper where he was
attacking
revealed christianity or attacking the
bible and the witnesses say that they
took it out of his hand and threw it
into the fire
but then when life tumbles in and it
does ultimately for all of us it was the
death of eddie first in 1850
then the death of willie in 1862 and
then the civil war lincoln must rethink
this he cannot go back to his parents
faith it's too emotional it's too simple
i argue that he gravitates to the
presbyterian church first in springfield
but most importantly in washington
because this offers him a much more
thoughtful rational approach to
christianity
and so here we find in this meditation
and there's been different dating dating
of it
where he's thinking for himself the will
of god prevails
in great contests each party claims to
act in accordance with the will of god
here you see the underline both may be
and one must be wrong
god cannot be for and against the same
thing at the same time all right here's
the logical lincoln
but then i think this next sentence is
really profound in the present civil war
it is quite possible that god's purpose
is something different from the purpose
of either party
and yet
he uses the instrumentalities working
just as they do or the best adaptation
to affect his purpose
lincoln was being besieged by both
ministers and politicians telling him
god is on our side and he knew that
jefferson davis was being also besieged
by politicians and ministers saying god
is on our side i love this photograph i
think it is a kind of reflective
thoughtful lincoln
and so here lincoln is working this out
he never thought anybody would ever see
this document
but as you think about it for a while
you realize it really is the foundation
of the second inaugural address however
you'd date it
a year before or two and a half years
before lincoln is asking the question
really where is god in the midst of the
civil war
sometimes i think it's been
misunderstood in a couple of different
ways
one lincoln doesn't know
no lincoln is humble he's not going to
be so arrogant to say i know
but he does believe that there's a force
working in the civil war
often the historians have used the term
fatalism to make that that the general
direction of lincoln's thinking is
causistic or determinative thinking but
i discovered a book written by an
episcopal minister in 1859
a man who had become one of the first
professors of the episcopal seminary in
cambridge massachusetts who said that
actually fatalism was a ver variety of
unbelief not belief
so i think lincoln is now on his journey
moved over against fatalism to a god of
providence a god who acts in history
and no one at the second inaugural knew
that lincoln had written this meditation
he didn't title it by the way john haye
found it in his desk in lincoln's desk
drawer
and hey a graduate of brown university
that's why it's there now he gave it the
title meditation on the divine will
lincoln did not title it but it's a good
title lincoln's thinking out loud what
is the will of god in the civil war
uh
you
you and iran are not reading many of
these fragments and notes
that's up to the reader and you
especially do that
in the appendix
now you have a co-author of this book i
do i hope he's getting royalties and
that's abraham lincoln
because in the appendix he wrote the
pages 166 to 279
and you may give a little context to
each one but that's all lincoln and you
ask us to read through them
and ourselves be interactive and try to
understand and question and
conceptualize what we're reading of
lincoln because there are 111 of them
there
and
you only go through uh
11 12 13 in the in the main part of the
book the rest is up to us to the reader
so they ask us to be interactive and
analyze it's so varied
the the
items there
um
you know he goes over
slavery the nature of labor
number of times he talks about labor
um
was a fragment for the house divided
speech certainly the longest response
i've ever seen for any autograph request
uh and there it is
robert e lee maybe
with his farewell to his troops at
alphabetics in general order number nine
rivals it in length but this is an
autograph request and and it's just
fabulous
uh and of course my favorite fragment is
they're a short one when you can't find
it anywhere else look into this
one of the uh one of the uh fragments is
a note to zachary taylor if he had
zachary taylor in front of him this is a
time in the 50s when the whigs were
trying to get into power
and what he often
and what he ought to say about policy
lincoln's saying to taylor
and i've asked others before
what the particular problems are of a
soldier
becoming a politician
versus a politician becoming a
commander-in-chief
so how did lincoln in this fragment note
uh
speak to taylor what was he saying to
him and how a soldier should look at now
this political office
well i almost included this one as a
specific chapter because as you suggest
it's fascinating
zachary taylor was for lincoln a logical
selection but not a persuasive one
he was a slave holder no one exactly no
one knew exactly what he thought lincoln
would have preferred to have had henry
clay again or someone like that
but he said if we're going to win this
election you know i got to admit this
guy's a military hero so okay
but three times in this fragment
lincoln says were i president
were i president were i president and
i'm just imagining that he's not even
necessarily totally speaking to zachary
taylor but he's saying if i were the
president this is what i would say
and that's what i found so amazing about
this we're i president so in a way he's
putting it in zachary taylor's mouth but
in another way he's putting it in his
mouth and i think it's a fascinating
fragment
another one of them uh was written in
october of 1858 at the end of the
debates
and where he says if he says a few words
of myself
now is that an anomaly for lincoln
speaking of himself and
in other contexts besides this one
well it is he often spoke in the third
person as we know when he writes his
kind of famous uh
autobiographical
contribution for the 1860 election he
writes in the third person which was not
unusual in the 19th century but that's
the way he writes so here again what i'm
arguing is that the fragment we hear the
i
person because he never thought we'd see
this
he's perfectly free to say this is what
i think what i believe what i feel yeah
but he didn't generally do that no he
did not generally do that no yeah right
right
right
uh
in
another uh
point uh speaking uh a fragment i should
say was speaking points for his tour
of ohio in 1859
fascinating uh but
i think one of the most important things
to have happened from that tour besides
introducing himself there is that
it resulted in the publication of the
lincoln douglas debates in 1860 yes
and
that is one of the mainstays of
how and why lincoln
became president
50 000 copies were sold
and distributed
and read and
that's he likes to say the cooper union
photograph and that speech made him
president sort of the debates and this
tour
and the speaking points are fascinating
to me
they are
and one of the points just stepping back
a bit is that some of the most important
fragments were written during the seven
debates with douglas in 1858 that here
lincoln is reading these various books
while he's you know his handlers are
saying we've got to get prepared for the
next debate to do this to do that but
lincoln is continually thinking
lincoln knew
lincoln often
there's a wonderful fragment on dred
scott
and that's before the debate before the
decision is made
but i often i argue in here that
sometimes lincoln would hold his fire
he would not immediately speak on a
subject
he had to take the time to walk across
the street from his law office to the
old state capitol where the library was
where he was getting himself prepared
and that in our day where everybody just
speaks immediately
lincoln
the greatest speaker in american history
would often not speak until he felt
fully prepared and i also argue that
when he argues in the notes for the law
lecture that we need to learn how to
learn speech to speak extemporaneously
that doesn't mean speak off the top of
your head
no it means be fully prepared but then
at a moment's notice in a particular
situation because you are fully prepared
you are then able to speak cogently and
persuasively
and you write about this in your
epilogue
that i mean i know i have
been like lincoln to the extent that i
write notes to myself and put them away
sometimes never used again other times
because i'm thinking something through
and later on i'll i'll think back and
say gee i was
wrong on this or correct on that
and uh you also do that you say in your
epilogue
and uh you know as you said it takes
contemplation as you've just said in
time without interruption
so just
briefly comment on your
reflections in the epilogue
something we haven't gramps covered yet
well i decided and here again i tip my
hat to my editor who said i know that
writers and authors and especially
academics
don't want to be personal
i say in the epilogue that when i was a
phd student at princeton university
a student asked the question said once
well what if a student asked about what
i think or feel and the professor said
don't answer it
[Laughter]
don't answer it
but she caitlyn mckenna said share a
little of your own personal point of
view
and the heart of that is i say i love to
speak to high school students
and i want to communicate to them and
i'm very concerned and worried about the
screens in our life
that are dominating our lives
we've learned through this pandemic that
lots of young people have spent even
more time on their screens because they
have been precluded from athletics or
all kinds of other things
and that lincoln
who we know from the gettysburg address
and the second inaugural was willing to
seclude himself in the white house to
say to his secretaries i don't want any
interruptions it takes time
and contemplation to write this way
but the way i begin the the book
is to tell this story in 1863
the audience will know who the
copperheads are this was a variant of
the republican democratic party who
wanted to return the nation as it was
and clement van landingham was an ohio
politician who was attacking lincoln
and they felt in his
ben nottingham's
adherents felt that lincoln was very
critical too critical
so lincoln received in the mail the
albany resolves which were attacking him
and he did what he often did was to
respond to these various protest
movements
at that moment a congressman from iowa
entered the office and he saw lincoln
writing out his response
they said oh my goodness this is
remarkable that you can sit down and
just write this response oh i said oh no
and he pointed to an open door of his
desk he said it's all in there
i have it all in there it's been there
for a long time
i keep these notes
and so i am arguing that lincoln had
these notes there
but those notes haven't been available
to us
and that's the whole thrust of this book
to say this is the way lincoln thought
operated wrote lead and now we can see
the private lincoln behind the public
lincoln
he didn't become the lincoln of the
gettysburg address or the second
inaugural without all of this
previous contemplation where he wrote
notes to himself
well this actually would be an a great
way to end uh but i'm going to put a
comma onto it and do on my own epilogue
very briefly let's keep this kind of
brief between us we were beginning
because you brought this up just now uh
contemplation and time to have that and
we were talking before the program uh
together about what was the happiest
time in lincoln's life time frame in
lincoln's life i put down new salem when
he was discovering himself
rafting down the mississippi perhaps
i mentioned that brief time between
lee's surrender and his death maybe as a
congressman
but i think the same as you is when he
was and you say this in the book when he
was out on circuit
uh i think that was a wonderful time for
him to be able to do what he loved best
speak about politics speak about the law
but i brought up the idea that and i
want you to comment on this that
one of the reasons he did not
go home
all the time when all the other lawyers
went home for the weekend or maybe even
a holiday he sometimes stayed out there
on circuit
all alone
and i think that was important to him
to be able to for the only time that he
had in his busy life to be alone to
contemplate to understand
uh what do you think about that
i don't think he was not going home
because he had a bad marriage is what i
i'm
proffering here i would completely agree
he did not not go home because he didn't
want to be with mary
this was a very important time to think
to
he also was politicking he was kind of
gaining adherence for a future political
career
but the eighth judicial circuit which is
twice the size of the state of
connecticut in central illinois
and here i tip my hat to our mutual
friend guy fraker who's helped me learn
about this eighth judicial circuit
that this allowed him the time to think
to you know we know the story that he
memorized euclid's principles their
theorems when he was on the eighth
judicial circuit i think this was the
happiest time of his life
he really enjoyed this time he enjoyed
the conviviality
but he also enjoyed what you suggested
the time to be alone to think and to
write some of these notes
yeah yeah so uh i since we're on mary
for a moment because you bring up marion
here and
mary lincoln and speak about the time
that she was uh in
an institution
uh that robert had put her in there
and i have some very definite ideas on
that strangely enough i happen to have a
bible wow
that i believe
was with her
1875. she writes her name yes
1875.
well that's just more than a coincidence
to me right
and i think that this was with her
in that asylum listen i think you're
right
and i want to uh ask you briefly about
mary and your thought because i'm we
have a another house divided interview
coming up in a month and i'll mention
that in a moment that
brings up mary in a big way
um
that
you speak about how myra bradwell who
was the first
lawyer lincoln a woman lawyer in
illinois she had to fight for that
and she and her husband helped bring her
out
um
of of there
and
to her sister elizabeth in springfield
and people have
been not so happy with robert for
putting her in there personally i think
and i want to ask you what you think
about this
that
she
robert and mary harlan his wife
couldn't have her come into their home
it would not work
and she needed someone at the same time
and i learned this from my mother
frankly when she needed someone in her
home she fought a tooth and nail and i
think mary did the same she would not
have anyone in her home
couldn't go to robert
couldn't be alone and wouldn't have
anyone there
elizabeth in springfield was ill
and could not handle her at that time
there was nowhere for her to go
so
she went into
uh
into the institution
and
but myra bradwell and also i think
elizabeth getting well herself in health
allowed
mary then
from robert to do it as soon as he could
he did it after a few months only
release her to elizabeth's care and she
was able to get out
what do you think of that
uh thought that
she was in there because there was
nowhere else for her to go
well i like that i like that
theory and and some of the lost letters
of mary lincoln that have been
discovered in recent years i think
substantiate the fact it's it's been
easy in the past to picture robbers the
bad guy in this
but i don't think that's necessarily the
case at all
and so
myra badwell's
role in getting mary released is quite
remarkable oh yes
and you write about it in this book a
fascinating story that is a sub story in
here
well ron
thank you so much we're going to get get
to questions from our audience uh but i
just want to say that upcoming on a
house divided here at the abraham
lincoln bookshop we the next one we have
is michael burlingame with an american
marriage
the untold story of abraham lincoln and
mary todd
this will be on june 1st
at 3 30 p.m central
time and i hope that you will
uh friend us on facebook and you will
get emails get your email into our
website so that you will know what's
coming up and so that's michael
burlingame on an american marriage june
1st
and on june 5th just four days later
timothy smith will come back for the
umpteenth time
with his new book the siege of vicksburg
climax of the campaign to open the
mississippi river and tim smith is a
wonderful writer and
incisive in his civil war writing i
think any civil war buff will enjoy that
june 5th
again at 3 30 p.m central time so
i'm so happy to be with you thank you
and bjorn you must have some questions
to uh from our vast audience yes very
good
well yeah there is a vast audience uh
dan this seems to be one of our most
popular programs so far so thank you
everybody out there thank you ron for
for writing a great book we have a lot
of questions and i
apologize up front to those of you at
home we may not get to everybody's
question because boy you really you
really talk yourself this time also it's
good that i had the mute on this whole
time otherwise you would have heard that
bell out there ringing every time you
ordered one of these books
uh again this has been one of our really
uh
uh thank you ron but this has been but
also thank you to those at home this has
been really one of our most
uh productive programs in that you're
buying the book even as ron is talking
about it
um
so i am gonna i am gonna share a few
questions that uh some folks have given
us
and uh ron if you could just do your
best here and uh but also knows there
are a lot of questions so we're going to
try to get through them
um
going to start with a question that has
uh some uh theology in it and uh my uh
my apologies to the customer who wrote
this but i i've done a little bit of
editing for brevity so this is a bit of
a paraphrase but ron
president lincoln had lost two of his
four sons as of the middle of 1862.
lincoln knew that he was sending
thousands of men to their deaths
we all heard of his severe bouts of
melancholy or depression if you will
which is justified based on personal
tragedy and having the weight of the
nation on his shoulders so here's the
part from scripture
when jesus faced his ordeal
he asked his father three times if
may this cup pass
in his notes did lincoln ever seem to
wonder
if
this cup
might pass from him
that's a very profound observation and
question
i think lincoln is very much weighted
down as you suggest in the question not
simply by the death of his two sons but
by the death of all of these other sons
and this is evident in some of the
remarkable letters that he writes to
wives to daughters to sons
my argument is
is that lincoln is much much more adept
theologically than we have given him
credit for
that many of the traditional biographies
simply say lincoln is for example
quoting the bible like one might quote
script of shakespeare in the middle of
the 19th century
but as for the second inaugural
in the previous 18 inaugural addresses
the bible was quoted only one time
lincoln quotes the bible four times
and he doesn't quote it at the end of
kind of which we find in modern
inaugural addresses and we need god's
help too
but he quotes all four verses very
substantively as part of his argument
for the idea that
the almighty has his own purposes
as lincoln suggests in the second
inaugural
so whether he's asking the question that
you asked may this cup pass from me
that's a interesting one i've never
faced that one quite before but i think
he really is operating at a very deep
level and as the meditation on the
divine will suggest
he's not even sure who's going to win
this war the will the the will the for
the war goes on wait a second he's
supposed to be winning the war he's the
commander-in-chief but no he's
ceding in a sense to a higher power
how the end of the war might become
might come right well thank you and then
i'll i'm going to follow up on another
question that has to do with uh uh his
methodology of thinking and this is from
jim johnson here in uh illinois
and jim wants to know we've seen
lincoln's logical methodology of
demonstration via euclidean principles
discussed in other books
what have you synthesized from lincoln's
notes which would further identify a
methodology embedded in his thinking
which leads us to a closer understanding
of him
well one of the revelations for me in
answer to your question jim is that
lincoln although he is logical and he is
euclidean in a sense he's much broader
than that and that's why the
fragment on niagara falls which i call
the lyrical lincoln
he's he's he's operating with a much
wider keyboard than i think sometimes we
have given him credit for
and what even his law partner william
herndon didn't fully understand
and the notes demonstrate how he can
come at an issue from various points of
view philosophically theologically
logically the point of view of a lawyer
deductively all of these are part of his
arsenal and this just to me
enlarges my appreciation for the wide
range of the way he can approach the
issues of his time
okay
uh bjorn before you get to the next one
i just want to say from that first
question i know who sent it i just want
to shout out to dale uh near buffalo and
east aurora thank you for that question
appreciate it good thank you dude
i know yes
let's move on to uh
i i promise everybody that ron has not
seen your questions but he keeps
suggesting the next question in his
answer to the one thing
i think that's because these are such
great questions right
but michelle michelle smith wants to
know uh with regard to the notes and the
destruction of of some of the
correspondence
she she asks robert todd lincoln is
alleged to have burned some of his
parents correspondence do we still
believe that is true
did he destroy any other papers
is there any relationship to personal
documents from the private thoughts that
you discuss in this book
thank you michelle that's a very good
comment i do address that in the
prologue
the question of how first of all hey and
nicolet are asked to collect the papers
and then they come into the possession
of robert todd lincoln
and the suggestion maybe
he thought as he transported them back
and forth here to there that maybe even
the notes and fragments didn't seem very
important they weren't official
documents maybe he didn't save them all
we know the story of the burn pile of
mary lincoln
burning correspondence and her papers
as they move to to washington for the
presidency did lincoln participate in
the burn pile
on the other hand there are there's
evidence which i show in the book where
lincoln writes a note in the 1840s and
brings it out in 1861
so here's an example of how lincoln
saved these notes
as i suggest i think he wrote hundreds
and hundreds of notes like you and i we
wouldn't save them all
that's i'm grateful we have 111 i wish
we had 311
but there's no particular evidence to
say robert did or did not i think we
might presume that perhaps he did
and and mary saved one
yes
this is the one that she gave to myra
bradwell when she was released from the
asylum yes so she gave that note to myra
bradwell yeah and that's on
you know i would not be a slave i would
not be a master right one of the most
important
and mary kept it and maybe felt
she was part of that that she i
we have bill shepard watching from here
in
in illinois
and uh bill simply wants to know uh uh
does the book contain all of the
fragments
or frag notes of lincoln that have been
discovered and preserved
perhaps in the appendix of the book
it does include all of them
every single one of them and with again
credit to the lincoln papers project and
i even put at the beginning some of the
symbols so you can see
for example maybe there's a place where
the editors cannot fully decipher a
particular word
things like that but all 111 this has
never been done before and i think
that's part of the distinctiveness of
the book
so the book is also a valuable reference
as daniel said earlier before it is it
is yes and we're called for us as i said
to analyze them ourselves
be interactive with this book yes yes
all right we're going to do one more
question before we just kind of do a
shout out to everybody and i appreciate
everybody who asked questions and uh
daniel and i may jump on facebook uh
uh don't jump on facebook here after
we're done and answer a few questions a
few addressed questions that didn't get
answered here but i do want to uh uh
give a shout out here and ask a question
uh today bradley who i believe is our uk
dave
hey
and so from over the pond i think i'm
right about this and dave asks would you
agree that one of lincoln's greatest
assets was his pragmatic pragmatism and
that this ability to see things as they
really were enabled him to deal with
situations and people as effectively as
he did his pragmatism
thank you dave if you are from the uk
about a year and a half ago i had the
privilege of speaking about lincoln and
oxford and that was wonderful
yes i like your suggestion that lincoln
was a pragmatist
i would make the distinction between
idealists and ideologues
lincoln had ideals but he was never an
ideologue
he was willing to encounter the
particular experience the particular
issue or problem and therefore change
his mind that didn't mean he didn't have
firm ideals
and so i think part of his part of his
effectiveness as a leader was his
pragmatism this is what
won his way through the civil war
i i love the story of uh of uh
of uh
when he's arguing over uh slavery
and uh should he emancipate the slaves
and he says we're opera i'm operating on
a different clock
and part of pragmatism is ask answering
the question what time is it and lincoln
had the
unique ability to know what time was it
to move forward on this issue or that
issue especially the issue of
emancipation
all right thank you very much uh for
that now i'm gonna very quickly
uh shout out to just some of the people
that are watching and again as i said
before this has become one of our easily
one of our most uh popular live
programs we've been there's been at
least 40 people watching for every
second
that that we've been on and uh you know
facebook analytics tells us that for
every moment that someone's watching you
know some people leave and then other
people come in so
we've had hundreds of people who've
enjoyed this live program uh up to this
point and i want to thank you all
i do we do have some of our friends out
there that are they're always there
dave bradley is from the uk
and so he's here bill is here from
illinois uh jimmy from alabama david is
here kevin from aurora illinois
tom and brian from
michigan john from tennessee hello john
thank you very much we're so glad to
have you
joining us on the live and uh just as
being a fan
a new fan of abraham lincoln bookshop
and
so i think daniel i am going to toss
this over to you to take us out
and uh if you have any last
any last thoughts
well you know as we go out of this ron i
just thought as we were listening to
some of the questions that have been
coming through
the im
the import of this book is also
that we're
dealing with some who wish to
destroy lincoln statues
for some
reason of lincoln's
failings
i think in this book
is a good answer
to what lincoln actually is whom he is
the breadth of whom he is
and that i think all of this in the book
is powerful reasoning
why we should
not be taking down but
building up more statues to him
he is one that we all should be looking
at
as
a moral exemplar
we even with failings he's a human being
a 19th century human being at that
we all have that but if we look at the
plus side of him i think that overwhelms
any of the human failings that he might
have as we all do
so i want to thank everyone
from those who are live with us
and those who are with us on c-span and
all of you who have seen this on youtube
because we also put this up on youtube
as all the others you can go in there
and see
many of our past interviews there
we appreciate your being with us ron
more than anything
we thank you for being who you are and
being the historian that you are and we
look forward eagerly to your next
missive as well thank you thank you dan
thanks to everyone who's been a part of
the program it's been very rich for me
thank you bjorn if you'll take us out
sure and so good afternoon to everybody
and we'll see you next time on a house
divided
[Music]